[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh this place does seem dope to me
martension darrell lee lashonio
barely yo and tis about time shakespeare
duff scrivened a play that places a
brother amongst the firmament that's my
sight
oh who's your favorite character monster
fellow oh his mind as well it's mine as
well
because they gotta tell her as a general
oh my god i'm saying
alex yes and othello did the beast with
two bats with that comedy white maiden
and it's not anyone speaking against him
he's straight pimping me thinks things
are looking up for people of the darker
hue
damn straight whoo hey
what's that i could borrow a couple of
duckets two purchases a capon from
yonder concession
more please you know i got a concealed
cornish game hand up in my doublet oh
a lot with me to partake it up in this
[ __ ]
the second act is about to begin come on
y'all oh y'all heard the ursher oh
if i know shakespeare i thought i was
about to kill everybody up in this [ __ ]
no no no i hate it this way how they
gonna kill othello
man that trifling ass iago i knew he was
up to some they should have killed tim
in the first act how they're gonna kill
it
and then how othello gonna do himself in
with a dagger how does that help let me
tell you something if a brother killed
himself every time
he broke up with a white [ __ ] this
world would be bereft of brothers you'll
be talking to a skull right now okay
where shakespeare is that shakespeare oh
he's right there with not the way okay
hey wait make way pretty make way be
gone sarah
you killed othello a black man got it
going on and you shuffle off his mortar
coil
i said unto thee that's a tragedy oh tis
that not the troubadour kanye of the
west what was
not waiting truth be told my lord
it is not i who penned this dreadful
play twist christopher marlow
[Applause]
already tried to use that line of
argument when the jews wanted to kick
your ass after the merchant of venice
we'd off not purchase it slick willy
we doth not purchase it be calm my good
lords
it will not be long before another black
hero grace at the stage and now if you
let me take my leader
not so fast you gonna write that hero
now verily that [ __ ]
that giant shaft is one bad mother shut
that mouth i just speak it's about shy
you